다시 돌아오신 걸 환영해요, "Quantum Computing in Practice"입니다. 저는 Olivia Lan이고요, 오늘 에피소드 3에서는
유틸리티 규모의 QAOA 실험에 집중해 볼 거예요. 처음부터 함께하셨다면 저희가
IBM 양자 하드웨어, Qiskit 패턴 프레임워크, 그리고 최신 오류 완화 기법들을 살펴보는 걸 보셨을 거예요.
연구자들과 개발자들이 양자 circuit을 확장하는 데 사용하는 것들이요. 이런 맥락을 모두 전달하는 게 정말 중요하다고 생각했어요.
방향도 보여드리고 싶었고요. 하지만 이제 이 모든 정보가 실제로
어떻게 작동하는지 보는 걸 더 미룰 이유가 없어요. 시작하기 전에 몇 가지 기억해 두실 게 있어요. 모든 것이 Qiskit
패턴 프레임워크를 따라갈 거예요. 순서대로 단계를 밟아 나갈 건데요. 1번은 문제 매핑, 2번은 circuit 최적화, 3번은
Primitives로 실행, 그리고 4번은 후처리, 즉 결과 분석이에요. 꽤 작은 예제로 시작할 거예요.
이 단계들과 그 목적을 잘 이해하실 수 있도록요. 그다음에는 비슷하지만 훨씬
큰 예제를 살펴볼 거예요. 100 qubit 수준으로 문제를 어떻게 확장하는지 보여드리려고요. 여러분 모두에게
이 강의 후에 직접 그 문제를 실행해 볼 수 있는 도구들을 드릴 거예요. 마지막으로, 이건 코드 따라가기가
아니에요. 아무리 노력해도 코드는 낡고 더 이상 안 쓰이게 되거든요. 그래서 만약 여러분이
이 영상을 출시 1년 후에 보신다면, 시간이 지나면서 조금씩 달라질 수 있는 문법에 얽매이지 않으셨으면 해요. 대신, 이건
논리와 문제 설명에 대한 자세한 논의가 될 거예요. 이 영상과 함께하는 노트북 튜토리얼이
아래 설명에 첨부되어 있어요. 코드를 따라가거나 시청 후에 참고하면서
직접 실행해 보시면 최고의 학습 경험을 하실 수 있을 거예요. 간단히 상기시켜 드리자면, 모든 계산 문제가
양자 컴퓨팅에 적합한 건 아니에요. 쉬운 문제나 단순한 계산은 이 기술을 활용할 필요가 없어요.
고전 컴퓨터가 이미 충분히 잘 풀 수 있거든요. 2024년 현재, 우리가 탐색에 가장 낙관적인
세 가지 분야는 자연 시뮬레이션, 복잡한 구조의 데이터 처리,
그리고 마지막으로 최적화예요. 최적화 문제는 계산적으로
효율적으로 풀기 가장 어려운 문제들 중 하나예요. 최적화 문제에서는 주어진 비용 함수의
최댓값이나 최솟값을 찾아야 해요. 하지만 관심 있는 많은 문제들에서 이 극값을 찾는 건
문제의 크기에 따라 지수적으로 어려워져요. 그래서 계산이 정말 어려워지는 거예요. 예를 들어,
전국에 걸친 최적 항공 경로나 배달 루트를 계산하는 게 얼마나 어려울지 상상해 보세요. 이번 강의에서는
Max Cut이라는 특정 최적화 문제를 탐구할 거예요. 이걸 양자
알고리즘인 양자 근사 최적화 알고리즘, 즉 QAOA로 풀 거예요. 그러면 Max Cut 문제가 뭐냐고요?
최대 컷 문제는 그래프 위에 정의된 조합 최적화 문제의 한 종류예요. 목표는
그래프의 꼭짓점들을 두 부분 집합으로 나눠서 두 부분 집합 사이의 엣지 수가
최대가 되도록 하는 거예요. 예를 들어, 여기 이 그래프에서 각 노드는 이렇게 연결되어 있고, Max Cut은 이 구불구불한
선으로 표시돼요. 노드를 보라색 그룹과 회색 그룹으로 나누는 거죠. 가장 많은
엣지를 가로지르는 방법은 이 그래프에서 다섯 개의 엣지를 자르는 거예요. 이 그래프는 너무 작아서
종이에서 몇 가지 컷을 시도해 보거나 머릿속으로도 다섯이 최선이라는 걸 알 수 있어요.
하지만 노드 수가 두 배, 세 배가 된다면 금방 손으로 풀기 불가능해져요.
그리고 어느 수준을 넘으면 슈퍼컴퓨터조차 최선의 답을 안정적으로 내놓기 어려워질 만큼 까다로워져요. 왜냐하면
최대 컷 수가 노드 수에 따라 지수적으로 증가하기 때문이에요. 다소 추상적으로 느껴질 수 있지만,
Max Cut 문제로 변환될 수 있는 실제 세계의 문제들이 많아요. 금융 분야의 사기 탐지, 그래프
클러스터링, 네트워크 설계, VLSI 설계, 그리고 소셜 미디어 분석 같은 것들이요.
소셜 미디어 예시는 특히 이해하기 쉬워요. 소셜 미디어 플랫폼에서 다른 사람들과 연결이 가장 많은
개인 그룹을 찾고 싶다고 해봐요. 파워 유저나
그룹에서 가장 영향력 있는 사람들을 파악하기 위해서요. 기업들이 실제로 꽤 자주 이런 걸 시도해요. 마지막으로 한 가지 더, Max Cut은 종종
더 큰 문제의 서브루틴이에요. 실제 응용을 직접 정의하는 게 아닐 수도 있지만, 내부적으로 사용되면
여러분이 막연히 생각하는 것보다 훨씬 더 흔해요. 이제 시작할 시간이에요.
첫 번째 단계는 그래프를 만드는 거예요. Python 패키지인 rustworkx를 임포트해서 할 수 있어요. 작업할
노드 수를 n으로 지정해서 정의하고, 그래프 G에 노드를 추가하세요. 엣지도
그려야 해요. 여기서는 이렇게 배열에 직접 나열할 거예요. 엣지의
가중치, 즉 지정된 두 노드가 얼마나 강하게 연결되어 있는지를 나타내는 마지막 숫자를 보여주는 방식이에요. 여기서는
모두 가중치 1로 할 거지만, 나중에 가중치를 바꿔가며 해가 어떻게 달라지는지
확인해 보시는 것도 재미있을 거예요. 가중치가 어떤 의미인지 감을 잡으려면 소셜 미디어 예시로 돌아가 볼게요.
이 가중치를 한 사람이 다른 사람에게 얼마나 영향력이 있는지로 생각할 수 있어요. 배우자나 친척과의 연결은
단순한 지인보다 아마 더 높은 가중치를 받을 거예요. 이제 그래프를 그려보세요.
첨부된 튜토리얼에 적절한 문법이 나와 있어요. 이 문제를 양자 circuit에
매핑하는 방법을 고려하기 전에, Max Cut 문제가 어떻게 최적화 문제가 되는지
맥락을 좀 쌓아봐요. 먼저 f(x)라는 함수의 최솟값을 구하는 걸 생각해 볼게요. 입력 X는
각 성분이 그래프의 각 노드에 대응하는 n차원 벡터예요. 이 함수를 앞으로
비용 함수라고 부를 거예요. 그다음에는 각 성분을 0이나
1로 제한해야 해요. 즉, 컷의 한쪽 또는 다른 쪽에 있다는 의미예요. 함수를
노드 쌍 xi와 xj로 쓸 수 있어요. 이게 해당 엣지가 컷에 있는지 알려줘요. xi + xj의 양에서
xi * xj를 뺀 값이 엣지가 컷에 있는지를 나타내요. 이 값이
1이면 엣지가 컷에 있다는 뜻이고, 0이면 없다는 뜻이에요. 컷에 있는 최대 엣지 수를 찾는 문제는
이 함수를 최대화하는 걸로 표현할 수 있어요. 다음으로, 실제로
이 함수에 전역 마이너스 부호를 추가해서 새 문제를 이 함수의 최솟값 찾기와 동등하게 만들 거예요.